you came from California just to do this
um I'm also shooting at a bunch of I'm
shooting a bunch of strippers as well oh
how cool I was doing that last night and
I'll be doing more tonight I had a
stripper pull in my condo oh you do
my condo is pretty kinky
I have a husband and a boyfriend so
oh really
and I'm like 60 67.
Maybe 68. and you've been a nudist for
how long about 30 years 30 years and and
the swinger thing happened first or the
nudism no actually I got into the
lifestyle and when I was 25. with my
husband and then I got out of it
and then I was the one that wanted to
get back in and I said let's get back
into my song of course you know my
husband's like yeah let's go so
um
the cup the boyfriend that I'm with
right now
he's um he's with somebody else too but
you know it all works out
so there's as it's been been explained
to me by some of the other people I've
interviewed there's different types of
nudists yes there's the more naturalist
who just want to live their lives naked
yes and then there are the swinger
nudists yes and you're you're a swinger
yes I'm in college tell me how the
swinger
element here is different than the
others different
I would say that much more sexual look
at people differently yeah you know your
eyes have a tendency to go down
on the man or whatever I'm the woman too
for me you like both I do I've liked
women since I was 16.
actually
and nudism facilitates more sexual
interactions yes you see what you're
getting before
you see what you're getting before you
get it does that make sense yeah
so there's a lot of like partner
swapping here
yeah I would say probably
50 to 75 of the people that come here or
live here are in some sort of Lifestyle
whether it's just watching whether it's
participating
um you know there's all kinds of
different things in the lifestyle that
you could do and the the swinger
relationship
what's different and interesting about a
swinger relationship as opposed to one
that's
committed in uh
well you can do them and go on or
sometimes you become friends with them
sometimes you do them once and never see
them again but we've made a lot I've
made a lot of friends from out of state
on uh online because I'm on a couple of
the
um swinger sites so there's swinger
websites and parties I'm sure you guys
get together and yes yes I have rehab
parties at our at our place and one of
the swinger parties look like are they
like people show up and everybody kind
of comes in they mingle
um
then somebody asked somebody if they
want to go to the bedroom so they go
back you know people come back and watch
you or sometimes they'll come back and
participate
uh nobody hardly ever closes the door
because the
enthusiasm and the sexual vibe from
watching the other people gives you more
sexual heightens your sexuality and your
sexual needs and desires or
does that make sense yeah it does
and
and it's the same like I noticed
everyone here is in a good mood
everyone's very pleasant very it seems
like almost everyone's in like I guess
for lack of a better way of saying it
everyone's in a good mood oh yeah and
and does the swinger element here have
the same
I would say so as long as both part both
pre both people like you know the male
and the female are into it a lot of
times the males are the ones that want
to be in it obviously the female doesn't
really want to
but she goes along with it just to
please the husband but I don't do that
I'm in it for the pleasure of myself I
don't whatever that the partner gets is
what they get so you were you were
married once before no I've been married
for 50 years I'll be married 50 years in
July oh so you're still married but you
have a boyfriend and your husband
understands yeah yeah we went to a
lifestyle party last night like I told
you in Lakeland and it was a buy
lifestyle party
they do a little interview they're you
know they have everybody they go you go
around they introduce that you introduce
yourself you tell them kind of like what
you like or what you don't like and then
everybody just gets naked after that and
walk around and you see somebody you
want to do something with you just ask
them but as always in anything no means
no
if you go up to somebody and they say no
thank you then you just go on you don't
hassle them what's your view on the way
most Americans View
sex
they're too uptight
they're so tight but I think also at the
same time
they
would like to do it themselves
they just don't because they're afraid
to be different or be afraid to call you
know bad names [ __ ] or whatever
um but it's really not that I don't
consider myself that you seem very happy
and content oh I am I am I love my life
I love my life my boyfriend buys me
anything and everything I want bought me
a Corvette convertible
we have our own little condo we have
adult parties I like watching him have
sex with other women he likes watching
me
a lot of times I'll just
do a guy and he watches
hang out and for you to be monogamous we
would just I couldn't do it I couldn't
do it I've not been monogamous since I
was 13 and or 16 somewhere in that age
frame
um even though I've been married 50
years I've always had
something on the side as terrible as
that sounds but
and not always that my husband knew do
you think this is the way that
all people
should naturally be or is it just
certain personalities take to it
can do it I think it's certain
personalities you have to have that
sexual being or that sexual desire
um I did have at one point where I
didn't really want anything to do with
sex I was
I don't want anything to do with this
with with my husband
but
I was promiscuous with other men
just you know go out
I had a boyfriend went to the bar
sometimes and you've never you've never
fallen in love but all of a sudden you
want that person all to yourself
I did with this one cop
but then
it kind of broke my heart
so I just learned to put up a shield
and it sucks and that's all it is knocks
up with my boyfriend that's different I
I really care about him would you say
you're an addict you're a sex addict
yeah
yeah I like to have sex at least
five times a week maybe six and you know
being sixty eight I'm gonna be 68 in
June you know that's kind of you're 68.
yeah you're 68. you don't like 68.
I'm trying to keep myself that way you
definitely don't act 68. no I don't and
usually if I see something that I want
female or male wise I'll attempt to get
it I don't you know I'm not
I don't get to just go up to them and go
hey you want to go to bed or whatever
but there's ways around it and you can
tell if they're attracted to you or not
I've
it's up here at a party not long a Super
Bowl party
and I ended up picking up this couple
black guy white girl and a lot of fun
it was great they went home with me and
we hung out and did our thing and
had a great time dude do you feel do you
feel bad for the rest of society that
plays by these rules that are very
stifling yes I do I do I think actually
my own view is that if the whole world
would just learn to relax a little bit
we wouldn't have all the problems that
we have today in the world and you know
I'm a very educated person I have a
master's degree in political science
I've worked in corporate world
um usually in corporate world you kind
of keep that a little low-key you don't
tell everybody what what you do you know
they said where'd you go over the
weekend
um had a picnic or whatever you know you
play it down because you don't want to
because sometimes the people that aren't
into that
it can it can kill your career yeah
don't judge you harshly yes and you know
what's so funny though is look at all
these senators and all these people they
get caught cheating
well you don't have to cheat you just
have to get your partner
into it
and then there's no cheating because you
both know what each other's doing it's
the United States we're very repressed
here yes we are
yes we are the others aren't though no
this is
do you have children I have one son and
I have one grandson my son is 48 and my
grandson is 21. and how does he view his
mom just as fun and and free spirit
he's a little
doesn't really like my lifestyle
doesn't uh appreciate that I have a
boyfriend
um and he knows I do
but hey it's my life and I'm not gonna
his guy has I'm not gonna make his life
minor I'm not doing what he wants well
you're certainly doing something right
at 68 to be having this much fun yes
and I'm so excited because
um Jimmy that I was sitting there with
the blonde he's gay
and uh he was going to get a membership
with somebody else and I said well you
know I'd really like to get a membership
I wanted to come up in the evening and
get in the hot tub and so forth and uh
so I'm getting a membership with him you
know split it costs each a little bit of
money each month a membership to what to
Paradise
but you live in a club but I'm not a
member oh I see see I I don't know if
you're familiar with Caliente or not I'm
not but at Caliente it's a it's a
five-star Resort it's a great place
um but if you live in there you have to
be a member here it used to be that way
you used to be have to be a member if
you lived here
well now you don't have to be a member
if you live here but I miss the the
party and it's the dancing
um and when Jimmy offered that I'm like
let's do it do you feel like the rest of
the country
outside of this little County in Florida
is is missing out yeah yeah they're
depressed
you know and the thing that I love about
the thing that I love best about nudity
is that
for the most part people aren't
judgmental that's that's a big thing I'm
seeing yes
women men are walking around letting it
all hang out and no one's sucking on
their gut no one's acting a certain way
no one's nervous about how they look no
you are what you are you accept yourself
and I think that's the greatest thing
because once you accept yourself
um you're gonna be happy that's maybe
that's what it is I've been struggling
with what it is that
why is everybody in a genuine good mood
here yeah like everyone seems like not
not a fake smile but like a genuine
smile a friendly warm smile from
everybody and I think it's maybe it's
that it's just everyone's everyone has
the freedom to be yourself so you don't
get depressed nobody's judging you do
people get depressed less here oh I
think so in this community yes yes yes
and you know we have a lot of older
older people that live here of course
not like I'm young but you don't have
like seven
and then I'm going on 70. a lot of 80
and 90 year old wait a minute scratch
that last one a lot of 80 and 90 year
olds that live here and it's just
I don't know have you ever tried nudity
no no you should try it you should try
it before you leave you should get in
the pool with no clothes on you would
love it you'd be like wow
what have I been missing
yeah I know I can see how it's very
freeing it must be very freeing right it
is it is you don't have and then once
you try it then you you feel so like
restricted afterwards I can imagine
right yes yes because you don't want
to hardly ever wear a bra and my nipples
are always
when I go out I don't want to fit bra on
so I don't and a lot of people would be
like oh you live in Paradise
they automatically know the people that
do and the people that don't in some
ways just because of the way we dress
I like to dress up I like to be sexy
um to the best of my ability
and I don't know I've always been that
way I've always been that way I used to
go to the 7-Elevens in a fur code okay
it could be you when you were young like
in high school well
not popular
I haven't actually curly hair so it was
naturally curly back then and then it
founded me they called me names
uh so it's really funny I went to my I
think it was like my 25th class reunion
and nobody knew who I was so like who's
that
so I just kind of like
you've gone wrong with your life
if you don't know why
you don't need to know who I am so and
tell me what your your parents your
family growing up
um they live in Ohio
they know I'm in it my my father's still
my father passed away when he was
61. you're raised in Ohio
around Dayton okay and I have one
brother and three sisters
they all know where I live
don't think they know about the
lifestyle thing
uh
this past year it's a shame that it has
to be a secret I know
I know they know I'm a nudist and they
also know about my boyfriend so they
kind of got to know you know yeah yeah
because we went to uh him and I went on
vacation together not not last year but
the year before we went to my
um mother's house I went to his family's
house and all they asked was his family
was like where's Carla who's the girl
that he divorced from now but Mary was
married is was married to and he just
said oh she didn't want to come along so
they're all like oh okay and you know
what it's really great is that
they all accepted me
for me and they I talked to him all the
time
you know on the phone or via email or
text or whatever I talked to most of
them so
and you've had jobs in your life your
careers
I was in government for a long time wow
city government
worked for law firms
I've been around the blocks so to speak
what do you think most Americans are
missing out on is is it freedom
is that what what's going on here that
that makes this community so happy and
different yeah I think that that people
are too uptight
you know take your clothes off and
I think that there's two million people
those apples there's too many levels of
um what do you call it
um
Society too many rules exactly you know
you have to be this way or you have to
be that way and I think that uh religion
plays a big part in this being bad
we were born naked you know it's my
Outlook on you're not hurting anybody no
no I'm not I'm not I'm not I don't uh
you know sometimes you approach people
being a lifestyle person I'm always kind
of looking at the person that in that
form
and if they're not they'll let you know
and you just go oh okay
and then make normal friends with them
so that's fine I have a great life I
can't say that I don't I worked in
Corporate America all my life I even had
a job interview at the Pentagon which is
really fun they flew me to uh Washington
did an interview I didn't get the job
but at least I got the interview
said that was pretty cool but you're
happy
yeah you seen it yeah everybody always
says she's always smiling what's wrong
with you everyone here is always smiling
I've been here for several hours now and
it's like
what's going on these are these aren't
fake pasted on Smiles these are these
are like just people that are happy to
smile at you yep yep we're just happy to
be here happy that we have this like
there's some lessons to learn here there
is there really is
don't be so uptight and you know my my
thing is is that we all have the same
parts
just some of them look better than some
others yeah well here it doesn't even
matter no it does not no it does not it
does not and I that's that's what I'm
not judgmental aside from the good mood
everyone's in it's that that lack of
body awareness exactly exactly you think
it would be the opposite but of course
yes yes now at Caliente
[Music]
um they have a they have a much younger
crowd that goes there although I noticed
quite a few younger people here today
um but those the people there are more
like the
beautiful people because you know
they're in their 20s I looked like that
when I was in my 20s too but
um and what I love is I get along so
well with the younger people
I'll go up to the table and just start
talking to him I do that sometimes I
went to this table at Caliente and I was
talking to this girl in the sky and I
went up there and of course
I I had taken my top off or something I
asked the guy I said do you want to feel
them
well his wife got a little testy no he
doesn't and I'm like oh okay
one night at the bar in here I was in
the I was in the bar and
everybody that walked by I said do you
want to feel my boobs do you want to
feel my boobs so there's this this
three couples walked by they were all
kind of like together or whatever and
the
the women are just like looking at me
like that well the guys came back a
little bit later because the women went
to the restroom and they're like
is that offer still stand
ing I'm like sure
go ahead
[Music]
all right Carolyn well thank you so much
for uh sharing your story thank you and
I wish you the best of luck out there
thank you have fun this weekend thank
you oh I will thank you
yes I have a great Italian line just me
and that's what I love about